Y
THE SAME RESPONSE OR HEAR IT,
WHAT CRIME?
JENNA CALDWELL TO FIND OUT FOR
HIMSELF HOW WASHINGTON IS
DEALING WITH THIS.
>> HE WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪ ♪
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CRIME CRISIS.
>> YOU ARE A LEADER.
I WOULD THINK YOU WOULD HAVE A
REACTION TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE COUNTRY.
NO REACTION?
>> MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISLES ABOUT THE
CRIME CRISIS IN AMERICA AND WHAT
TO DO ABOUT IT.
THE FIRST DAY REPUBLICANS ARE
VICTORIOUS IN NOVEMBER, YOU
BECOME THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
WHAT WILL THE COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA DO FOR CRIME?
SPEAK WITH THE FIRST DAY, YOU
WILL SEE NO LONGER WILL THE
VOICE OF WASHINGTON BACK HERE
WHERE THE DEMOCRATS CONTROL
DEFUND THE POLICE.
IT WILL BE THE OPPOSITE.
>> A ROAD PACK FOR AN ECONOMY
THAT A STRONG NATION SAFE FROM A
FUTURE BUILT ON FREEDOM AND A
GOVERNMENT THAT IS ACCOUNTABLE.
>> WE WILL SCORE EVERY SINGLE
PROSECUTOR FROM PORTLAND TO
PHILADELPHIA.
THEY GET FEDERAL MONEY.
WE WILL ACTUALLY SIT THERE AND
HOW THE DEBATE.
THEY DESERVE THE FEDERAL MONEY
IF NOT UPHOLDING THE LAW.
>> THE MAJORITY IS BLACK ON
BLACK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN DO
ABOUT THAT AS A COMMUNITY?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT THING HOW
WE DEAL WITH THIS LONG-TERM.
WE HAVE TO GET OUR KIDS EDUCATED
BLACK, YOUNG MEN.
THEY WILL BE YEARS LATER LIKE
WHERE WE ARE NOW, CRIME ON THE
WAY UP AND SEE NOTHING WRONG
WITH IT.
>> IT IS A MISCONCEPTION.
EVERYTHING IS HAPPENING IN THE
URBAN AREAS BUT IT IS HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE.
BEAT UP, ROBBED IN A PARKING LOT
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
>> WE SPOKE TO SOME REPUBLICANS
AND HOW WE WILL TALK TO
DEMOCRATS, HOPEFULLY.
♪ ♪
>> LET ME STATE CLEARLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY, BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
>> WE JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE CRISIS WE HAVE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION.
>> CONGRESSMAN NADLER,
[INDISTINCT]
>> MAY BE, I'M VERY, VERY BUSY.
>> TOMORROW, DOES THAT WORK?
>> WE WILL REACH OUT TO YOUR
OFFICE, CONGRESSMAN PURITY WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE CRIME
CRISIS IN AMERICA.
>> THE EASE WITH WHICH PEOPLE
ACQUIRE GUNS IS STILL A BIG
THING.
>> CRIME IS NOT OUT OF CONTROL
IN OUR CITY.
>> IS MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT DOING
A GOOD JOB?
>> I THINK SHE IS DOING A
GOOD JOB, AND I THINK SHE WILL
BE REELECTED AS MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
>> THAT IS FRIGHTENING TO ME,
BUT KIM FOX, YOU THINK SHE IS
DOING A GOOD JOB?
UNEQUIVOCALLY AND WITHOUT A
DOUBT.
>> VIOLENCE IS BAD, VERY
SENSIBLE BUT NOT THE
OVERWHELMING PICTURE IN
NEW YORK.
>> SENATOR IN A REACTION TO THE
CRIME CRISIS IN AMERICA?
CRIME IS UP, IN A REACTION?
YOU ARE A LEADER AND I WOULD
THINK IT WOULD HAVE A REACTION
WHAT IS GOING ON THE COUNTRY.
>> I SUPPORT THE REFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT.
>> CRIME ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS
IMPACTING STUDENTS.
>> WELL, OUR WORK ON STUDENT
DEBT CANCELLATION IS A RESPONSE
TO WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER POLICY
VIOLENCE.
>> YOU MENTIONED POLICY VIOLENCE
BUT I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
I KNOW POLICY VIOLENCE BUT I
JUST WANT TO KNOW, DO YOU FEEL
THE POLICE SHOULD STILL BE
DEFUNDED?
WE WILL SET IT UP.
>> WE NEED TO COMPLETELY
DISMANTLE THE MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> IN A REACTION TO RISING CRIME
IN AMERICA?
YOU SUPPORT OF THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT THAT LED TO
RISING CRIME BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY
REACTION?
ANY REACTION?
NO REACTION?
IT IMPACTS YOUR CITIZENS.
♪ ♪
>> Neil: WOW, NOTE TO SELF,
NEVER GET ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
CALDWELL.
HE WANTED ANSWERS.
GIANNO CALDWELL, I DON'T THINK
YOU GOT THEM, DID YOU?
>> NO, I DIDN'T GET THEM AND I
WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED BUT I
THINK THAT IS A HUGE
UNDERSTATEMENT, NEIL.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT THEIR CITIZENS AND WE
HAVE CHUCK SCHUMER WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE WHO
REFUSES TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
WHAT IS ON EVERYONE'S MIND.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED 2020
AND MURDER RATE INCREASED
NATIONALLY BY 29%.
YOU LOOK AT THE FBI REPORT THAT
CAME OUT AND THEY WERE SAYING
WHAT HAPPENED IN 2020-2021 WAS
FAIRLY CONSISTENT.
THAN YOU REALIZE 40% OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WEREN'T INCLUDED
INCLUDING NEW YORK AND
LOS ANGELES INTO THE FBI REPORT.
THINGS ARE MUCH WORSE THAN WE
COULD EVER IMAGINE, NEIL, THE
CITIZENS OF THE COUNTRY ARE
PAYING A PRICE FOR THOSE WHO SAY
THEY WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE
AND FOR THOSE WHO SAID THE
POLICE WERE NOT NEEDED IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND WE SEE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE TODAY HERE.
>> Neil: YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO
WILD ABOUT IT.
WE HAVE HEARD IT FROM
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT HERSELF IN
CHICAGO WHERE TRANS ACKLEY THE
YOUNGER BROTHER, CHRISTIAN WAS
KILLED, BUT IT IS FINE.
THIS IS AN EXAGGERATION.
SHE WAS LECTURING THE CEO OF
McDONALD'S FOR MAKING A BIG
DEAL ABOUT CRIME.
RIGHT NOW, TYSONS IS MOVING OUT
OF THE CITY BECAUSE OF CRIME.
AND YET, IT IS NOT A PROBLEM OR
IT IS AN EXAGGERATED PROBLEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST, EITHER
LORI LIGHTFOOT'S GASLIGHTING OR
ATTEMPTING TO CAST LIGHT OR SHE
IS SO INEPT, SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A REAL ISSUE.
MY CONCERN, ESPECIALLY AFTER
TRAGIC SHOOTINGS AND MURDERS AND
SO MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING MY BABY
BROTHER CHRISTIAN WHO WAS
MURDERED SEPTEMBER 24TH.
THEY WILL LEAVE AND GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE, MIAMI AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY DEAL SAFE
AND WANT TO LIVE AND WORK.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CITY?
IT BECOMES A DESTITUTE CITY.
THEN YOU ARE REALLY IN TROUBLE
BECAUSE HE STILL HASN'T
RECOVERED FROM THINGS WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE '60s.
THAT IS A PROBLEM AND WE NEED
THE LEADERS TO WAKE THE HILL UP.
THAT IS WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
THEY NEED TO WAKE UP AND
RECOGNIZE THIS AS AN ISSUE THAT
IS IMPACTING EVERYONE.
THIS IS IN A REPUBLICAN ISSUE OR
A DEMOCRAT ISSUE.
IT IS A HUMAN AND THE ISSUE.
THEY NEED TO START LISTENING.
I'M OUT FOR JUSTICE, NEIL, FOR
THOSE LIKE MY LITTLE BROTHER AND
THOSE LIKE HIM, INNOCENT VICTIMS
OF CRIME CRISIS IN AMERICA.
I WILL NOT STOP HERE THAT IS WHY
I WENT TO D.C.
IT WAS A BURNING SENSATION IN MY
HEART I NEED TO GET OUT THERE
AND TALK TO ELECTED OFFICIALS
RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
I WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE FIGHT AND
IT DOES NOT STOP HERE AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR
ANSWERS AND SOLUTIONS TO THE
VIOLENCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, NEIL.
>> Neil: YOU KNOW GEON OH, I
KNOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZABLE FACE
AND YOUR BROTHER IS AN
INTERNATIONAL STORY WHAT YOU HAE
BEEN DEALING WITH.
SO, I FOUND DOUBLY INSULTING TO
DISMISS OR WAIVE YOU UP AFTER
WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN THROUGH AND
THE PASSION YOU BRING TO THIS.
AND I'M THINKING TO MYSELF, IF
THEY CAN TREAT SOMEONE WHO
EXPERIENCES AND IS SORT OF
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS, MY GOSH,
HOW WILL THEY BE TALKING TO
ANYONE ABOUT THIS?
HAVE THEY TALKED ABOUT IT AT
ALL?
>> WELL, THAT IS THE
POINT, NEIL, THEY ARE NOT
LOOKING TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THE POLL 77% OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE THAT CRIME IS A MAJOR
ISSUE.
THE LATINO ISSUE, THIS IS THE
NUMBER TWO ISSUE IN THEIR BOOK.
AND YOU THINK ABOUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING AND WHEN IT COMES TO
THE LECTURE MIDTERMS AROUND THE
CORNER, REPUBLICANS HAVE A BIG
EDGE ON THE CRIME CRISIS IN
AMERICA BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT THEM
TO FIX IT.
DEMOCRATS, OF COURSE, DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT, BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THEY EXACERBATED IT
SAYING "WE NEED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE."
YET THEY HAVE SECURITY AND PAY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR IF NOT A MONTH TO PROTECT
THEM.
WHY DON'T WE AS AMERICAN
CITIZENS DESERVE THAT SAME
PROTECTION?
WHY IS IT DEEP ON THE SOUTHSIDE
OF CHICAGO FOR HER TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES?
WE HAVE KIDS THAT DON'T WANT TO
GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW IF THEY WILL BE MURDERED.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
CHICAGO IS A THIRD WORLD
PROBLEMS.
WE NEED TO MAKE CHANGES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, AND WE NEED THEM
NOW.
I WILL NOT STOP, NEIL, I
GUARANTEE THAT UNTIL WE SEE
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> Neil: YOU HIT HOME ON ANY
ISSUE IS THAT THE PROBLEM WITH
NOT EVEN ACKNOWLEDGING THE
PROBLEM ON